♪ ♪
>> Laura: THE EYES OF THE
WORLD ARE ON OTTAWA TONIGHT.
YOU HAVE TOW TRUCKS, THEY'RE
ALREADY ON STANDBY IN EARLIER
TODAY POLICE BEGAN A MASS
TICKETING.
THEY ARE COMMITTING A CRIMINAL
OFFENSE AND YOU MAY BE ARRESTED.
THEY EVEN TOLD PROTESTERS THAT
THEY WOULD BE PUSHED OUT BY
TOMORROW.
MEANWHILE JUSTIN TRUDEAU'S
TACTICS HAVE SPARKED A MASSIVE
BACKLASH ABROAD AND AT HOME IN
FACT JUSTIN TRUDEAU WAS TAKEN A
TASK ON THE FLOOR OF PARLIAMENT
OR HE LET HIS TRUE COLORS FLY.
>> IF CANADIANS ARE TO TRUST
THEIR GOVERNMENT, THEY NEED TO
TRUST CANADIANS.
IT DOES THE WORDS THE
PRIME MINISTER IN 2,015.
THESE PEOPLE, VERY OFTEN
MISOGYNISTIC, RACIST, WOMAN
HATERS, SCIENCE DENIERS ARE
CRINGE.
SAME PARENS MINISTER, SIX YEARS
LATER AS HE FANS THE FLAMES OF
AN UNJUSTIFIED NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
>> CONSERVATIVE PARTY MEMBERS
THEY CAN STAND WITH PEOPLE WHO
WAIVE SWASTIKAS.
WE TALK ABOUT CANADIANS WHO NEED
TO BE ABLE TO GET TO THEIR JOB
GET THEIR LIVES BACK.
>> Laura: COURAGEOUS MEMBER OF
PARLIAMENT YOU JUST SAW MOUSSA
LANDSMAN JOINS US NOW THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US TONIGHT.
TELL US WHAT WAS GOING THROUGH
YOUR MIND WHEN YOU HEARD HIS
REFERENCE TO SWASTIKAS?
>> THIS IS NOT A SURPRISE TO ME
YOU JUST SAID IT, THIS IS JUST
HIS TRUE COLORS I SIT THERE AND
WATCH HIM DIVIDE AND WEDGE AND
STIGMATIZE CANADIANS EVERY
SINGLE DAY AND TODAY THE REST OF
CANADA SAW A G7 PRIME MINISTER
GO AFTER A JEWISH MEMBER OF
PARLIAMENT AND THEN WALK AWAY
AND NOT APOLOGIZE.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK THERE'S
ANTI-SEMITIC ELEMENT TO THIS OR
WAS IT JUST A SLIP, A VERBAL
SLIP?
>> I THINK THAT WORDS MATTER AND
IF YOU LOOKED AT MY INBOX AND MY
OFFICE AND YOU SAW WHAT MY STAFF
WAS LOOKING AT, WHEN YOU ACCUSE
SOMEBODY OF STANDING WITH THE
SWASTIKA YOU GET AN INFLUX OF
PEOPLE CALLING YOU A.
THAT IS NOT OKAY.
AND HE IS DRIVING IT.
HE HAS BEEN DRIVING DIVISION IN
THIS COUNTRY THROUGHOUT THIS,
SINCE THE PROTEST STARTED AND
BEFORE THE PROTEST STARTED FOR
HIS POLITICAL GAINS.
I GUESS LEADERSHIP IS IN
TROUBLE, THE COUNTRY IS IN
TROUBLE AND HE HAS LOST CONTROL
THE SITUATION.
>> Laura: I WOULD LIKE TO PLAY
WHAT HAPPENED WHEN HE DID DEMAND
THE APOLOGY FROM JUSTIN TRUDEAU
WATCH.
>> I THINK HE OWES ME AT AN
APOLOGY AND I THINK HE OWES AN
APOLOGY TO ALL MEMBERS OF THIS
HOUSE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: HE ACTUALLY LEFT
AFTER INSULTING YOU LIKE THAT.
THAT WAS HIS RESPONSE RUN AND
HIDE THIS KIND OF HIS TRADEMARK
AT THIS POINT YOUR REACTION?
HE HAS LOST CONTROL NOW JUST
GIVE YOUR VIEWERS I CAN'T CALL
THAT OUT THERE'S A WILL SAY THAT
I CAN CALL THAT OUT.
BUT HE WAS NOT THERE.
HE HAS NOT APOLOGIZED AND I
EXPECT AN APOLOGY AT THE TELL
YOU THAT CANADA IS THE BEST
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
MY PARENTS CHOSE IT I'M A
GRANDCHILD OF HOLOCAUST
SURVIVORS AND TO WATCH WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH THE
PRIME MINISTER IS DRIVING THIS
COUNTRY IT'S FRANKLY EGREGIOUS.
>> Laura: HOW MUCH HATE HAS
BEEN DIRECTED AT YOU AND OTHERS
WHO DISBELIEVE AND FREE
EXPRESSION AND THE RIGHT TO
PROTEST?
EVEN TAKE AWAY CONCERNS ABOUT
MANDATES AND THE TRUCKERS AND
CROSS-BORDER TRAFFIC SET THAT
ASIDE.
HOW MUCH HATE HAVE YOU SEEN OUT
THERE JUST DIRECTED AT YOU?
>> I THINK THE DIVISION IN THIS
COUNTRY IS GROWING AND IT IS
GROWING BECAUSE OF THE PRIME
MINISTERS RHETORIC ON THIS.
GIVEN URBAN RURAL DIVIDE.
I'M THE PARTY'S TRANSPORT.
WE HAVE BEEN CALLING TO AN END
THESE MANDATES, PARTICULARLY THE
MANDATES SINCE EARLIER THIS
YEAR.
WE ARE ONE OF THE HIGHEST, OR
THE HIGHEST VACCINATION RATES
WE'VE ALSO HAVE THE HIGHEST
RESTRICTIONS.
SO HE WANTS AND THUS TODAY HE
COULD'VE DONE THAT 19 DAYS AGO
BEFORE PUTTING FORWARD A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY THAT IS NOT
JUSTIFIED HE COULD'VE GONE OUT
AND TALK TO PEOPLE RATHER THAN
CALLING THEM RACIST AND
MISOGYNIST AND WE COULD PUT AN
END TO THIS.
WE CAN DROP THE MANDATES AND HE
CAN DROP THE RESTRICTIONS TODAY,
I FEEL LIKE WE WOULD HAVE A MUCH
MORE COHESIVE RHETORIC.
>> Laura: THANK YOU VERY M